did you just say is everyone here stoned
because
we're doing a freestyle rap people over
here what would you like a rap about
[__] amazing ventriloquism that was
incredible
what was the suggestion
you are actually sat there what's your
voice is pervasive it's like it's like
God is suggesting things himself did you
just say trains yeah yeah yes I'm so
excited for this because the tone of
your voice suggests you are of a level
of autism where you know every train
possible
yeah
I I used to work with autistic kids my
brother is autistic and so he's very
intelligent if you give him a Rubik's
Cube takes him 12 seconds to say thank
you
trains I love it trains suggestion
number one I know you like I know you
like old trains is an easy thing to wrap
up don't worry we're gonna make it like
monotonous trains it's gonna be good so
this section over here which one rap
about
did you just say is everyone here stoned
because
if you couldn't hear that in the most
Lana Del Rey voice ever she was just
like
here with him is he holding you hostage
and you've been
absolutely sedated are you sure blink if
you can to suggest she's doing this
um okay so power lines
trains power lines so there's some hands
up at the back yeah you're waving this
is great what would you like a rap about
Pluto no longer being considered a
planet do you do you work in space no no
you work in beverage
I guess you know there's the food and
beverage industry and you're like yeah
[__] the first half
average for life okay Pluto no longer
being considered a planet power lines
trains this corner here what would you
like a rap battle
crosswords lovely stuff which is your
favorite one to do New York Times sad as
if I'm an idiot for doing anything else
it's the one for the purest Chris
okay crosswords
um and then there's there's the table
right at the back are just waving
enthusiastically yeah what would you
like a rapper
I I couldn't hear that
Zuckerberg vs musk oh because
um yeah because they're gonna fight in
in what in Jiu Jitsu cage fight oh [__]
cool
great to the death that would be good
winner winner takes all becomes
musk versus Zuckerberg power lines
trains this is this is going to be
adequate now I don't think I know
obviously we remembered Pluto not being
a planet and beverages
um and then I wonder if it was
crosswords okay this is what we're gonna
do we can do a freestyle about all those
things DJ do me a favor drop that beat
and this is what I said it's gonna be a
freestyle rap made up on the spot based
entirely on that do not worry it will
not be anywhere near as atrociously
embarrassingly toe curlingly [__] as you
are expecting it to be you've seen so
unconvinced
[Music]
don't harm the kids in the UK we're
slightly more naughty we don't do 110 or
120 we double 240. I caught these
frazzle on the fingers if you've got a
ladder long enough then you can bring
this bird's purchase on I'm like oh
shoot how are these feathery friends not
electrocuted
slightly sedented guide on your lap like
yes applicator she be there basically
out of her mind then you drop back to
life and you say power lines with
slightly more energy than one do there
we took one simple breath of air he
inhaled and then he exchanged he says
from his vocal cords trains that's what
I love and I show this I emotive about
the locomotive Stevenson's rocket that's
the first of the kind but now you've got
that Amtrak with the power lines
overhead it takes a longer time to play
no car but don't worry you'll be
lowering your carbon footprint wouldn't
you think that's worth the cash actually
it's really [__] expensive first
class can't afford that so you're flying
in coach lady at the back see me like I
really hope you rhyme about Pluto there
used to be nine but now only eight
planets they can Define my very simple
matter or easy method speeds up naming
what well the peas up time's up they
drop it off I can really see it's so
small in the distance and look so icy
they say it's not a planet anymore of
course they say it's basically a block
of ice a tiny dwarf you're just rubbing
it in this case what do you think you're
a [__] planet and I work in drinks ah
the details where the devil is no need
for food I'll be getting beverages I'll
be pulling all the Taps I'll be serving
all the beer is that what it means you
like this Street's clear and this one's
cloudy so this one's worse between all
your pipes I'm feeling White Turf quite
tense why because I've really observed
it's absurdly hard for me to solve the
New York Times crossword one across
names a planet ah [__] I thought Pluto
would fit I can't stand it five letters
well then what could it be Venus
probably you need to be I'm quite venal
I really carry myself with pride I peel
the white boxes in the block I try and
hide and if you get it wrong just look
up online you can find the cheat say yes
we're going some time to have the fun
the lady at the back remind me girl
because the mine's gone slack of course
we got it feeling in Rage you've got one
angry billionaire they're in the cages
like hello there I live in San Francisco
it's not his voice but just let it go
for this show Mark Zuckerberg he slings
with the hook he's like I stole the idea
for Facebook from the Winklevoss twins
I'm Coming For You Elon and musk has
just done lines of coke he's on some
real crazy [__] he's like bye get away
he calls in his tag team partner that's
grime she comes in and shrieks at the
dudes ah Elon and Mark have you proved
he goes and he punches him and then goes
too far and elon's gone he's just [__]
off to Mars and there the Zuck is left
he's like hey I'm the Victor today in
the BJJ because that's a little sport
that he picks dude the nerdy Facebook
looms that does Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
[Applause]